52-річний Бенджамін Грзімек з Дюсельдорфа збирається в Україну. Знову.
Упаковує одяг, медикаменти, їжу, іграшки для дітей.
Чоловік уже вдягнув свою улюблену футболку, в якій завжди
їздить в Україну як волонтер…
Хоча ще годину тому сидів у білій накрохмаленій сорочці
на офіційній зустрічі в офісі.
Дякую всім, що прийшли, я знову їду в Україну.
Кар'єра юриста у сфері патентів, підлеглі, світлий просторий офіс.
Чоловік все поставив на паузу - аби їздити в Україну
з гуманітарною допомогою.
У нас був дзвінок з клієнтом, а Бен не зміг до нього підключитися,
здається, це було за день до цього, бо місто, у якому він перебував, бомбили.
Мантія для відвідин суду поки сумує на вішаку.
Цього тижня на судовому засіданні його замінять колеги.
Сам він активно планує маршрут для поїздки.
У паспорті Бенджаміна вже 3 сторінки заповнені штампами
про перетин України. Він не стомлюється, не жаліється
і чітко розуміє навіщо це робить.
Це атака на всю Європу, а Україна наразі - лише поле бою.
Я думаю, що в Європі це теж наша війна.
Ми допомагаємо, деякі з нас роблять більше, ніж інші, і це нормально.
Також допомагає країна - грошима і тим, що потрібно для захисту.
Де саме і яка допомога потрібна - координує українська
організація "Голоси дітей", яка підтримує постраждалих
від війни і з якою співпрацює Бенджамін.
Також у підготовці та зборах юристу активно допомагає Редіет Мелаку
- ефіоп за походженням чоловік з малечку живе у Києві
і вважає себе українцем. Від початку повномасштабної війни
разом з дружиною і двома дітьми виїхав у Німеччину,
і так доля звела його з Бенджаміном, який пропонував
свій дім для прихистку українців.
Це вони привезли з Києва.
Тепер Бен і Радік - так вони кличуть один одного - друзі.
Інколи Редіет їздить із Бенджаміном в Україну - возити гуманітарку.
Або ж допомагає на місці.
Наступна зупинка у підготовці до поїздки - офіс німецької
громадської організації Dobrosvit, яка допомагає українським дітям-сиротам.
Найбільша проблема - це гроші. У всіх є час, енергія,
але гроші...це виклик.
Звісно, від війни всі втомилися… Ми теж втомилися.
Але це не виправдання.
Ми відправляємо наразі на Дніпропетровщину LifeSaver Cube.
Це такі спеціальні каністри для дезінфекції, стерилізації води.
Це означає, що одна каністра, її фільтр може стерилізувати
до двадцяти літрів води. Ми відправляємо також таблетки
для очищення води, що дуже важливо.
Наша допомога йде до дітей-сиріт.
Ці каністри та таблетки - те, що Бенджамін повезе віддавати в першу чергу.
Усе зібрано, завантажено - час вирушати!
Тисячі кілометрів позаду…
У Харків автівка Бенджаміна приїхала напівпорожньою,
адже основну частину гуманітарної допомоги вже вивантажив
у Кривому Розі та в Нікопольському.
Я привіз 40 коробок із цими каністрами.
А інший тип продукції, який я привіз, - це більш складні,
більш високотехнологічні фільтрувальні установки для лікарень.
Я був у двох лікарнях, одна була в Зеленодольську, що на південь
від Кривого Рогу, а друга - у Нововоронцовці.
І ми з місцевими фахівцями встановили фільтрувальні установки,
і обидві працюють. Я дуже радий, що ми змогли це зробити.
Близько 40 тонн гуманітарної допомоги за час повномасштабної
війни особисто організував та привіз німець.
Я був в Україні більше 10 разів. Якщо порахувати всі поїздки,
то напевно більше 15 разів. Я перестав рахувати, якщо чесно.
Якщо мій фургон заповнений, я намагаюся їхати якомога швидше.
У харківському центрі допомоги українським сім'ям
Бенджаміна зустрічає керівниця Олена.
Все для дітей
Наразі у їхньому спільному плані - створення дитячої майстерні,
де діти могли б проходити психологічну терапію у форматі творчих вправ.
Ми мріємо створити майстерню, щоб діти могли приходити
і навчатися щось конструювати. Ми мріємо, щоб був педагог,
який приходить до дітей і вчить їх щось робити руками,
що це будуть інструменти, що там Бен зможе дістати.
Якщо це буде напрямок столярний, то знайдемо майстра столярного,
якщо це буде електричне щось, то буде електричне.
Крім цього з планів на майбутнє у Бенджаміна - ремонт кухонь
у студентському містечку університету імені Каразіна у Харкові.
Ідея - знайти необхідні речі для обладнання кухні.
Щоб тут стало краще, щоб люди могли готувати кращу їжу,
їсти разом, а не їсти лише концерви чи готувати собі супи,
а потім все це їсти наодинці.
Нині студмістечко переобладнали у притулок для людей
з деокупованих територій.
Був просто коридор.
Все, що ви бачите, зробив Бен. І ремонт, і меблі, і все, що є.
У нас є чотири ноутбуки та чотири планшети.
Сьогодні восьмеро дітей мають можливість прийти в цю кімнату
і зробити уроки, або просто відпочити, подивитися мультфільми,
пограти в якусь гру.
Всі ці проєкти Бенджамін втілює разом із благодійним
фондом "Голоси дітей". Саме вони й познайомили німця
з контактами в Україні й координують його допомогу
- як дітям та їхнім родинам, так і військовим.
Хотів купити ще, але не вистачило коштів…
Це дуже відволікає наших військових. Малювання картин, мозаїка,
різноманітні роботи - вони дуже розслабляють і релаксують.
Гадаю, я повинен сказати собі, що маю бути задоволеним.
Але я ніколи не буду задоволений, тому що робота не закінчена.
Я завжди хотів би мати більше машин, більше водіїв,
більше пожертвувань і більше співпраці.
Бенджамін не тільки допомагає сам, а і об'єднує навколо
допомоги українцям інших. Це не волонтерство, а повноцінна робота,
каже чоловік. Тільки разом можна наблизити перемогу.